you think Aquaman's the first of the
superheroes in this in this new
reimagined world that you can sit down
and have a beer with that's how you see
Aquaman yeah I mean he's he was
definitely as long as like a yeah as a
blue-collar man he's raised by his
father and you know who worked on bikes
and trucks and you know his dad was
all-american and I just built yeah he's
definitely somebody could sit down have
a beer with right he can't do that with
Superman again I mean it was going he's
in the fortress of solitude there's just
crystals it's Wayne you know you're
hanging out I'm in the bar I'm in the
bar during the bar and you're having a
beer and you're approachable
yes that's what Aquaman and just smell
like fish real earthy now you have
oh you and you he likes to party this
man right oh yeah yeah III think that
the difference is it's you like to have
a beer but when you go out with Jason
it's not a beer it's a ten it never
happens he shows up with it because it's
like hey let's go get a beer dude it's
like 15 people they've been tailgating
already and it's just it's hard to hang
it's been they've been pre partying for
four years what you wouldn't do I bring
my own wine
you got your wine your book that's not
how these guys roll we roll this my
everything yeah all right so you are you
love your beer and you really love
Guinness is that true yeah I hung out
with you in Belfast not too long ago and
I noticed that you you were very
interested in in having Guinness you
really like to having Guinness yeah and
you have your own you're such a kind of
store of Guinness isn't this true you
have your own special blend of Guinness
that the company's made with you is that
right two of them two of them what well
how does that work how does one go to a
bar and say I'll have a Guinness when
they start to pour it go no the Momoa
Guinness how does that happen you
tailgate for four years I mean I've said
before I met my I've always had it and
I've met my wife to over a pint it's
just something that you know not a lot
alcohol and I just work really hard I
train really hard and then at the end of
the day you know dog wants a bone and
that's my well my little I'm told I was
told just before we did the interview
that you were generous enough to bring
along some Guinness for everybody that
we could share is that true
yeah yeah let me make something clear
everybody okay let me get something here
you're getting the goddamn pop dolls
okay if I start handing beer out the
police are gonna be all that mean
why don't we bring the beer out guys
will enjoy the beer hey we have a
trailer that we're going to watch for
Aquaman good anything anything you want
to say sir about the trailer before we
see it no here it is the trailer the joy
[Applause]
[Music]
my brother has come from the sir
me for the throne I got an ass-whooping
no leader
because I have no choice
I can't save my home and the people that
I love
you think your unriddle lead which is
you have two different worlds
that is exactly why you are worthy
oh it's awesome
coming to the surface
of the seven seas with me
[Applause]
[Music]
redheads
first cows rectum okay with you right
back
you